so for those of you who follow me on
Twitter and periscope I had mentioned
that in addition to my videos as part of
the road to Civil War I would also
continue my series on the Marvel power
hierarchy at the same time I had asked
you all to post questions in the comment
section of the second video on things
you needed more clarification for as
they pertain to this topic and because
there were 400 different replies I've
spent a part of the last couple weeks
coming over all of them and so I'm
hoping that this video will provide the
clarity you guys are looking for as well
as allow us to move forward with the
rest of this topic
the first and most common question asked
was whether or not the cosmic entities
of male comics still exist in the
all-new all-different marvel universe
the answer to this question is yes and
it's teased in two sources but confirmed
in a third the first two sources come in
the form of all-new all-different star
brain and night masks and all-new
all-different Ultimates regarding star
brand a night mask because both of these
heroes serve as harbingers of the
universe in order to keep it protected
from various threats much like the
Silver Surfer their escapades within the
first five issues saw them traveling
into space itself as well as dealing
with a cosmic Marvel landscape as a
result and Wallis only momentary issue
number three established that eternity
was present in the all-new all-different
marvel universe and maintained his
previous position prior to the events of
Secret Wars and that eternity exists as
the physical manifestation of the
universe and came into existence with
the creation of the Marvel prime
universe itself now regarding the
all-new all-different Ultimates as a
group composed of black panther blue
Marvel and others who serve to protect
the Marvel prime universe from
multiversal threats
the first issue saw the return of
Galactus as the devourer of worlds who
was transformed into the light bringer
due to the Ultimates efforts and curing
his hunger now for the definitive answer
to our question this comes with Jim
starlings graphic novel infinity finale
now while the graphic novel does take
place within its own self-contained
universe outside of the bubble prime
continuity and focus on the actions of a
nihilist from the negative zone looking
to take over that reality at the
conclusion of the story jim Starlin tied
the events into the post secret wars
universe as well as the greater marvel
cosmology and the final events of the
story following the defeat of Annihilus
Thanos and Adam warlock
were brought before the one above all
who made the case that with the original
Living Tribunal haven't been killed
during the events leading up to time
runs out a new tribunal would need to be
appointed to take its place and ensure
balance was maintained throughout the
multiverse now where Stalin does not
address why the one above all took no
action against the beyonders during
their crusade to wipe everything out as
part of the bargain to restore that
reality Adam warlock had undertaken the
position as the New Living Tribunal in
addition to this the traditional cosmic
entities from the free secret Wars era
including eternity and infinity had
referenced the death of the previous
Living Tribunal and the events that led
into seeker wars that said the next
question I saw being asked frequently
was in relation to the Phoenix force dr.
strange and beans from other dimensions
now where these were characters that I
intended to cover in a separate video
due to their being different versions of
them with each depiction having varying
levels of power because this was so
popular we'll go ahead and we'll just
cover it right here so starting with the
Phoenix force this entity exists in
three forms the normal Phoenix the Dark
Phoenix and the white Phoenix of the
crown the normal Phoenix is the version
of Jean Grey seen during the original
Phoenix saga as well as the form taken
by Rachel summers and Hope Summers in
this form the powers of these characters
are amplified several times over and
their capabilities allow them to exceed
the Celestials placing them just under
eternity in terms of power as for the
Dark Phoenix this version is more
powerful than the standard Phoenix force
due to the removal of its volt compass
although this form still remains weaker
than eternity now for the white Phoenix
of the crown this version actually steps
into the true purpose of the Phoenix and
has only been attained by Jean Grey and
Hope Summers with hope having only been
the white Phoenix of the crown for a few
minutes in this form the white Phoenix
is elevated from being a universal
entity to a multiversal entity and
exists to literally travel into
universes and eliminate what doesn't
work now where this is extremely
ambiguous its meaning is a little
lackluster and that this explanation
basically just allows Marvel to have the
white Phoenix do whatever they want her
to
and that's it there's really nothing
more to it than that so I'm sorry for
you guys who were hoping for a deeper
meaning here but there isn't one it's
just a plot device socialization into
Doctor Strange much like the Beyonder
and Owen Reese strange exists in two
forms free retcon and post read comment
however while beyond ER and Owen Reese
had clear-cut reductions to their powers
in a single story dr. strange was not
this way
instead the reduction of his abilities
came over the course of a decade or so
as different writers used different
stories to make his character more
relatable as opposed to being wildly
overpowered now there was a particular
moment whereby dr. strange actually had
his powers taken away from him by the
vishanti but while they were returned
this is kind of considered to be the
tipping point whereby if his powers were
being reduced over the course of decades
this was a straw that broke the camel's
back that basically put his abilities in
a place where there was no going back to
the way they used to be before in terms
of prereq on Doctor Strange his
character was quite literally able to do
everything including astral projection
cosmic awareness dimensional travel and
manipulation flight control over the
elements instantaneous healing the
ability to return people from the dead
telepathy telekinesis time travel and
teleportation
basically it was one of these things
that if you can think of it there was a
spell somewhere that he could use to
make it happen and so the result was at
the original powers of dr. strange
placed him above the cosmic entities but
below the Living Tribunal in terms of
power however following the various
reductions of these abilities the powers
of dr. strange made him much weaker
resulting in him being on par with the
various cosmic entities or a little
weaker than them now four other
dimensional beings the issue would
quantify these characters is that they
have never really had any contact with
the mainstream Marvel Universe - the sky
fathers and the Olympians instead the
measure of their power comes in the form
of earthbound characters referencing
these powers directly as an example the
most powerful of these beings and the
arch-nemesis of Doctor Strange comes in
the form of Dormammu while he has never
actually entered the mainstream Marvel
Universe an amazing spider-man number 58
from 2003 Doctor Strange had made the
case that if
mama would ever enter the mainstream
Marvel Universe his power would extend
into the multiverse with no one not even
the Lilly tribunal being able to stand
against him now for the rest of the
other dimensional beings including CID
Iraq
Ikon Shuma gorath ragged or with Tim and
Michonne T where they are largely viewed
in the same capacity as Dormammu in
terms of their abilities on the whole I
would consider these beings on par with
a living tribunal this pertains to the
Visconti especially due to the fact that
the bolt of doctor Strange's powers both
pre and post retcon hail from the
vishanti themselves indicating that
their power is seemingly limitless now
for those of you who are curious about
the source of dr. Strange's powers well
actually get into that a little further
as we get closer to the release of his
film but at this point I want to
continue on with our discussion by
branching into several other characters
who bring under the Marvel cosmic
entities in terms of their power but are
also part of this overarching question
about other dimensional beings looking
to rune King Thor Odin
Serdar Zeus and Mephisto these beings
each exist within their own pocket
dimensions and routinely cross over
where the characters from Earth thus I
check here for a second when it comes to
pocket dimensions the best way to
understand this is that if a house is
the main model universe the various
closets represent pocket dimensions
which can be accessed through different
dimensional portals like the Bifrost or
simply sheer force of will regarding
them King Thor during the Ragnarok event
which had seen the death of Odin as part
of its leader Thor had undertaken a
sacred journey which endowed him with
the odinforce and the power of Asgard's
ancient runes which endowed him with
godlike abilities now there is some
debate among comic readers as to whether
or not rune King Thor could take out a
single celestial but because his powers
exist in isolation and that he never
encountered aden or battle a celestial
and only appeared in three issues it's
impossible for us to know for sure
but in my mind because Owen was
destroyed by a single celestial despite
using the full power of the odinforce
and the destroyer armor it would stand
to reason that rune King Thor would not
fare any better now if you want to learn
more about routine Thor I have a video
explaining this in more detail but
transitioning to Surtur
he hails from the realm of the fire
demons called Muspelheim
and is the arch-nemesis of odin as such
his powers are relatively limited in
number and that they consist a
superhuman strength endurance longevity
dimensional travel and magic but exist
on such a scale that he's virtually
impossible to kill with the exception of
those listed above or equal to an in
power in terms of odin his power hails
from the odinforce
which is more of an amalgamation of
energies originating with Odin absorbing
the life energies of his brothers viele
and V the own force is almost limitless
in his capabilities the downside here is
that because it serves as the source of
Odin's energy much like a battery if
Odin uses too much of this power at one
time he enters something called the Odin
sleep which allows him to reach hard to
the odinforce now for Zeus he exists as
the Olympian equivalent of Odin but
where Oh de News's the odinforce to
power himself Zeus and the rest of the
Olympians are powered by humanity's
belief in them in addition to this Zeus
is able to magnify and amplify his own
power set and reduced the abilities of
other parts of his powers meaning he can
increase his strength by sacrificing a
portion of a speed and durability for
any combination of the three as a result
in terms of overall power Zeus and Odin
are largely considered to be the two
most powerful of the sky fathers a
belief that was held by comics fans for
years but confirmed in 2014 Stannis
annual number one that transition into
the sky fathers themselves these beams
represent the traditional gods of
various historical cultures on earth
including but not limited to Odin Zeus
Vishnu and Osiris now what we haven't
seen the true power of each of these
beings outside of Odin and Zeus there
have been a couple of instances when the
collective abilities of the sky fathers
have proved formidable as an example
because of Celestials had engineered the
deviants eternals and mutants the
decision was made that the group would
travel to earth every thousand years or
so and investigate their efforts to this
end when the third celestial host
arrived over a thousand years ago the
sky fathers were forced to remain hands
off after the Celestials had threatened
to seal the barriers between the pocket
dimensions
the sky fathers in Earth and so while
they did allow this to happen when the
for celestial hosts had arrived in the
modern day
Odin drew the life energies of all the
Asgardians except a Thor into himself
enter the destroyer armor and alongside
the sky fathers engaged in battle with
his Celestials now while the group was
defeated almost immediately the power
they possessed was enough to at least
receive acknowledgment of worthiness
from the Celestials themselves someone
also note here is that regarding Doctor
Strange while free retcon Doctor Strange
was far beyond the sky father's post
retcon Doctor Strange was far weaker
than the sky fathers finally regarding
Mephisto like the sky fathers he exists
within the realm of his own pocket
dimension similar to hell but populated
by those who swore fealty to him in
exchange for earthly pleasures to this
end while Mephisto can enter the realm
of Earth his power begins to decrease
the longer he stays away from his
dimension however in terms of his
abilities his powers are energized by
the evil of the Marvel Universe and
include godly intelligence immortality
and magic which enable him to achieve
are truly any effect he desires
including shape and size manipulation
illusion projection and time
manipulation allowing him to stand as
one of the cosmic entities but on a
lower level placing him equal to the sky
father's but weaker than the Celestials
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end and I hope it
answered some of the questions you guys
had as always feel free to post
questions down in the comment section
and I'll answer them as best I can and
yeah so I will catch you guys on her
please